pendant des centaines d'années le monde
à exister sans la vision
tu crois que parce que tu peux voir ça
va te sauver non mon père est baba voss
[Musique]
il va venir me chercher
aucune distance ne sera trop long
aucune site est trop dangereuse aucune
arme est trop forte
il fera n'importe quoi
protéger sa famille
il vous fera payer pour ça
moi je vais pays
il me doit bien plus que tu ne pourras
jamais imaginé je suis le commandant
général et aux fausses
[Musique]
ça faisait longtemps mon frère
c'est moche on peut monter jusqu'à 200 m
l'obélisque de washington à mesure que
169 m en somme ça qui montra le plus
haut le budget qui lui sa richesse va
penser l'exposition universelle
je vais pas recommencer
tu vois pas l'intérêt on serait un
machin qui sert à rien qui va faire des
goûters juste après vous avait réponse à
tout
la vie m'a appris à me méfier des
surprises
[Musique]
ça car tour j'espérais ne jamais vous
fait oui à bas pour y avoir des idées
sur le sujet du concours il faut voir
plus libre plus audacieux une tour 300
mètres entièrement en métal
un défi à la gravité
vos éléments
cette tour messieurs c'est paris
son rayonnement
sur place dont
pourquoi tu m'as pas tout dit
lui même je te parle pas d'amour
je t'ai parlé réputation briller trop
grand trop haut
paris est contre nous
ils en sont même à compter le nombre de
morts que la tromba ferdaus écran
[Applaudissements]
c'est scandaleux je pense qu'un scandale
que nous allons entreprendre personne ne
l'a jamais tenté nous allons construire
un rêve
cette tour les gars c'est celle de la
france
c'est surtout la vôtre jaloux c'est
ensemble qu'on a commencé
c'est ensemble qu'on va l'achever
ab1
[Musique]
alors ta télé alors je porte je suis
désolé c'est ma mère me dit on n'est pas
cinq minutes j'ai allumé et sur la télé
y a écrit un texte 1 alors que moi je
veux voir tf1 m en fais trop qui
commence comment fais tu appuies sur
menu et après tu choisiras la source
elle y arrivera pas a dit tadic menu
menu ces maisons maman menu ces maisons
pourquoi tu me dis menu si ces maisons
donc tu sais quoi je te battrais ta
série ce soir sur le replay bon soit il
peut pas savoir ce que c'est merci à
cause de toi j'ai raté mon feuilleton je
t'ai dit que j'allais te mettre en
replay pourquoi est ce qu'elle a dit à
ripley le replay mme amina csu streaming
sur comprend rien à ce qu'on raconte en
ski maison
[Musique]
ils vont n'importe quoi avec les
horaires champagne tranquille tous
l'aider
maman tu disais que tu viendrais dormir
à la maison un séjour et pour la
récurrence c'est aujourd'hui
bon aller 2 2 mais comment ça de dos
je dis ça je ne suis pas là je suis une
petite abeille carole carole oui maman
chérie ça comme ça avec ton mari si vous
voulez avoir un beau pas de problème
j'ai mes boules quiès merci maman je
pense que le message est bien passé
serveur que maman est la moins de 20 cm
maintenant tous ici
ces boules quiès ah oui pardon j'ai à m
[Musique]
oui ce sera parfait pour la soirée
échangiste tu veux parler de la soirée
troc restaurer ou en échange les objets
on échange quand même le plaisir est
donc rentré tard à l'histoire ils sont
juste ça traîne toujours en longueur et
soirée et ce soir ils sont juste parce
que bon le bridge scrabble
au bout d'un moment vous fais ça depuis
quand mais ça fait des années je sais
déjà que mon mari lui il aimait pour y
trouver qui avait trop dessus
bon effectivement ce serait mieux c'est
plus de jeunes ça vous dirait de venir
non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hvm coup c'est cette soirée m'a cassé
les pattes
[Musique]
jeannette
nous voulons que le jury vous
soutiennent mais vous êtes loin de
donner l'impression que c'est vous la
partie visée il ya plus détesté du pays
vous voulez que je lui ressemble plus
c'est ça
jamais tu as c'est ça ouais c'est mon
anniversaire joyeux anniversaire
on veut tous qu'on ne peut pas avoir
même si on doit changer pour l'obtenir
je crois qu'un jour je serai une jolie
fille populaire si c'est ce que tu veux
il ya des moments dans la vie qui nous
change pour toujours quelquefois luce a
disparu depuis maintenant quatre jours
[Musique]
la dernière chose au monde dans cette
ville de merde avait besoin
c'était une autre quête wells
c'est sûr tu n'aimes pas moi je suis
vraiment accroché
tu penses toujours à kate non
je crois qu'elle a fugué c'est soit ça
soit c'est l'autre solution janet lève
toi dont avocate et là quelle importance
est ce que tu crois que rien ne sera
jamais plus comme avant pour être
honnête je n'arrive même plus à me
souvenir comment c'était
tu l'as vu non bien sûr que tu sais que
jamais je te mentirais j'allaite sterns
avec l'humain m'améliorer et d'un coup
du jour au lendemain il est devenu et
l'autre atteint
ce qui est arrivé à cette fille est une
tragédie mais ce qui t'arrive à toi je
ne peux même pas loin
[Musique]
j'ai personnes qui me soutient j'ai plus
rien être mais pas celle que vous croyez
tu viens de dire quoi là le mal les
verts parmi nos juste sous nos yeux
[Musique]
un an
j'ai vécu des tas de vie mais cette fois
je ne ferai pas mon passé
j'étais onctueuse
une espionne et un avenger
les avant ça j'avais une famille
c'est un travail à terminer on va se
battre avec toi
[Musique]
à
tout va bien super perf
[Musique]
surtout la partie auger faye signalement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
durant des milliers d'années
le lien entre mes enfants et moi était
parfait
aujourd'hui une présence obscur menace
de détruire la maçonnerie
je suis mbo de kandhamal la chercheuse a
plus génial de toute la zone
les niveaux tu fais une petite fille
exceptionnelle tu as été désigné par les
esprits salut toi on est désespérés dix
mois s'est dit long les mois record 7
mois descendre si tu assistes
ses doigts qui doit sauver le village il
faut que tu sois forte
nous devons les arrêter sauf condamné
il est temps pour nos d'être courageux
bull courage
c'est magnifique j'ai dû avoir très fort
en toi même à vous envoler
oh
[Applaudissements]
ce pas trop ça fait cent ans que je n'ai
de personnes
[Musique]
ses patins ou ce cas là
imaginez l'appareil le plus perfectionné
le plus performant le plus sophistiqué
qui ait jamais existé mais si ce n'était
pas qu'un appareil
s'il devenait votre meilleur ami salut
voici le bebot jamais vous n'aurez été
aussi connecté exprimez vous donner
libre cours à votre imagination
créée et jouée et donner une nouvelle
dimension à l'amitié
le vix bottes notre meilleure année
anniversaire à retardement barney
ça lui a serré le nom de l'utilisateur
je suis ton nom ton mon big mat by
bottes le plus bas qu'il a quelque chose
qui va pas c'est pas censé faire ça je
ne suis pas censé faire ça
je sers à se faire des amis barney a
besoin d'amis ben ouais ça va pas le
faire il aura du mal à survivre au
collège
addis abeba réseau sync
je suis le meilleur avis de insérer le
nom de l'utilisateur plus dans sa boîte
[Musique]